مستمرين مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في تغطيه
اخر تطورات المشهد في السودان يوم عاشر
اذا من المواجهات بين الفقاء السلاح يوم
عاشر يفاقم من معاناه المدنيين البعض اثر
النزوح بعيدا عن مناطق الاشتباك ثم يعيش
اخرون تحت القصف ووسط انهيار شبه كامل
لنظام الرعايه الصحيه وازمه مياه وفيما لا
يبدو ان حلا قريبا يلوح بالافق اثر الدول
عده لاجلاء رعاياها واغلاق السفاراتها
والى غرب دارفور حذر والى غرب درفون طبعا
هناك حذر من تصاعد الاشتباكات في الولايه
ودعوه للتهدئه في حين حذر الامين العام
للامم المتحده من تبعات العنف في السودان
وقال انه ينذر بحريق كارثي في المنطقه
السودان
[موسيقى]
لا حول ولا قوه
وفي اخر التطورات الميدانيه اعلن الجيش
السوداني استقرار الموقف العملياتي الجيش
اشاره في بيانه الى توسيع نطاق تامين
منطقه الخرطوم لتجنب الحاق اضرار بالمناطق
السكنيه فيما جدد دعوته لعناصر الدعم
السريع بالاستسلام بيان الجيش اتهام قوات
الدعم السريع باستخدام المدنيين كدروع
بشريه واكد البيان ان الاتصالات ما زالت
مستمره مع الدول الاجنبيه الراغبه في
اجلاء الدبلوماسيه
بالمقابل اتهمت قوات الدعم السريعه الجيش
بتنفيذ غاره جويه على احياء سكنيه متفرقه
من العاصمه الخرطوم اليوم مؤكده انها
استهدفت المدنيين بشكل مباشر في حي الدوحه
بام درمان ومنطقه الكلاكي الى جنوب
الخرطوم قالت في بيان لها انها تعمل على
تقديم الخدمات الاساسيه وفتح الممرات
انسانيه في هذه المرحله الصعبه التي
تشهدها السودان الى جانب انشغالها باجلاء
البعثات الدبلوماسيه ورعى الدول الاجنبيه
اظهرت مقاطع فيديو حصريه لقناه العربيه
حجم الدمار والاضرار التي خلفها القصف على
منطقه الكلاكله القبه الواقعه جنوب
الخرطوم فلنتابع مشاهدي
المنطق
شكله
في بيت وقع الان
بار ده
لا يخفى عنكم جميعا احنا متقدرين
نشد طلاب من قطاع غزه عبر العربيه
لاجلائهم من الخرطوم فلنتابع مقاله
اليوم الان ليش الضفويه
وفي المق
ابل الفلسطيني
اذا مشاهدينا هذا الفيديو الذي نتابعه هو
مناشده لطلاب من قطاع غزه عبر العربيه
لاجلائهم من الخرطوم طبعا بعد كل
الاشتباكات الداميه والمواجهات الداميه
التي ما زالت مستمره بين قوات الدعم
السريع وبين الجيش السوداني عمليات
الاجلاء بدات منذ ايام وهي تنحصر الان على
الدبلوماسيين على البعثات الدبلوماسيه على
الرسميين الموجودين داخل السودان على ان
تستتبع لاحقا بعمليات اجلاء للمدنيين ولكن
طبعا هناك صعوبه بهذا الموضوع بسبب عدم
تامين وامانه الطرق التي طرق البريه طبعا
للوصول الى بورسودان وللوصول منها الى
خارج الخرطوم اعود موجودين بعد من الخرطوم
تقريبا ما يعادل ساعتين او ثلاث ساعات
ولكن بسبب الطريق والمشاكل اللي واجهناها
في الطريق طلعنا منه الصباح من الساعه
2:00 من الساعه 2:00 صباحا على اساس نقدر
نوصل الساعه ثمانيه هنا من الساعه 2:00
لما تحركنا ما حركنا الا خطاب من السفاره
ونزل كشف من السفاره باسماء الطلاب اللي
قالوا انهم يتحركوا علينا الكشف هذا كان
فيه تقريبا 117
اسم 17 اسم بناء على كشف السفاره قالوا
لهم تعالوا من الولايات اللي في الولايه
البعيده يجي من الولايه اللي هو فيها بناء
على كلامهم جابونا على اساس انه هتتحرك
البساط على الساعه ثمانيه احنا الان
قاعدين في الشارع قاعدين في منطقه هنا
اراك سيتي بحيث ان مش لاقيين مكان نقعد
فيه فعليا الشباب تجمع الشباب الموجوده
الان هنا ما يعادل تقريبا 120 شخص
ما يعدل تقريبا 120 شخص واقفين في الشوارع
باغراضهم وبسنتهم باغراضهم فانا بقول لك
هذا هذه الطلاب كلها موجودين انت الان ليش
تجيبني قاعد من الولايات تحطني في الخرطوم
في اساس النزاع وفي مناطق النزاع ومناطق
الطخ والسلاح اللي شغال عندهم هنا احنا
اليوم في المنطقه اللي احنا فيها لقينا
فشك قسما بالله ورصاص احنا بعدين يعني مش
بعدين منه احنا في نفس المكان احنا الان
مرفوعين يعني تخبينا في منطقه سكنيه بحيث
اننا نقدر نرفع مثلا عن الخطر عنا قدر
الامكان ليش تحركني من البدايه ليش تحركني
من البدايه وتجيبني من الولايه عشان تقولي
لي بدي اعمل لك اجلاء الصباح على الساعه
ثمانيه والساعه ثمانيه الاقيك طلعت باص
واحد تبعين الضفه الغربيه
الضفه الغربيه اليوم طلعوا تحركوا لميناء
بورتسودان ومن ميناء بورتسودان هيتحركوا
عن طريق
جده عن طريق البحر الى جده ليش احنا
كمواطنين مثلا من غزه ليش احنا كمواطنين
من غزه موجودين ليش تتعامل معنا بهذه
الاليه الان جبتنا وبتقول لنا انا مش قادر
اعمل لكم
اجلاء طب انا طيران
حرق اسبوع ثاني من المواجهات المسلحه في
السودان لا صوت يعلو على صوت الرصاص ولا
مؤشر ينذر بحل قريب المواجهه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع بدات باطلاق نار كثيف حول
مباني المدينه الرياضيه في منطقه سوبا
جنوبيه العاصمه الخرطوم القتال انتقل
سريعا الى حي المطار المتاخم لمقر القياده
العامه للجيش حيث يوجد بيت الضيافه الذي
يقيم فيه طرفاء الحرب البرهان ودجل وكبار
القاده العسكريين وسط الخرطوم وبينما
تداولت وسائل الاعلام عن الدعم السريع
السيطره على مطار مروي والقاعده الجويه
اضافه الى الاعلان عن احتجاز عدد من
الضباط الذين كانوا طبعا في القاعده تم
هنا تداول معلومات عن استيلاء قوات الدعم
السريع على القصر الجمهوري في قلب الخرطوم
اضافه الى اجزاء واسعه من مقر القياده
العامه للجيش نيران الحريق امتدت بعدها
الى خارج الخرطوم
عددا من المدن مثل نيالا والفاشر والجنينه
وفي ولايات دارفور ومدينه الابيض في ولايه
شمال كردفان القتال تركز ايضا حول مقرات
الدعم السريع في شارع عبيد ختم في مدينه
بحري وام درمان ليس معروفا على وجه الدقه
من يسيطر على ماذا فكل طرف يزعم بسط
سيطرته على مواقع استراتيجيه قبل ان يبادر
الاخر سريعا لاعلان الشيء نفسه
[موسيقى]
وثقت مقاطع مصوره تصاعد اعمده الدخان في
محيط السفاره الكويتيه بالخرطوم اثرى
الاشتباكات الدائره فالمتابعه الصور
[موسيقى]
تحركنا من منطقه الخرطوم الى منطقه على
بعد حوالي 1200 1300 كيلو
صعب انك تخرج من بيتك
نقطه يعني كثير فيها
وبينما تستمر عمليات اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب من السودان مع استمرار المواجهات
قال لواء بحري ركن صالح بابكر عمر قائد
الفرقه 101 مشاه في البحريه السودانيه
للعربيه قال ان هناك تسهيلات لاجراءات
دخول السفن وطبعا سفن اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب حاولنا نسهل كل الاجراءات
المتعلقه
بالمواني بدخول السفن
ورباطه وايضا بوصول الرعايه هنا وتجميعهم
وضيافتهم وما الى ذلك من من اجراءات حقيقه
كانت عمليات الاجلاء يعني مشهد بالطريقه
سلسه جدا
سهلنا كل الاجراءات حتى الاجراءات الرسميه
للجوازات
والجمارك كانت في مكان استقبال هذه
الجاليات الان احنا بصدد عندنا الان بتحمل
ثلاثه سفن اللي هي سفن من المملكه
من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وعندنا سفينه هنديه
وعندنا سفينه كوريه جنوبيه وفي انتظار عدد
اخر من السفن الحقيقه
بحث وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان مع نظيره الاماراتيه الشيخ عبد
الله بن زايد جود وقف اطلاق النار في
السودان وزير الخارجيه الاماراتيه تمنى
دور المملكه في عمليه اجراء رعايه
الامارات والعديد من دول العالم من
السودان الى السعوديه مشيدا بجهود البارزه
التي تقوم بها السعوديه بتنفيذ عمليات
الاجلاء بالتعاون مع مختلف الدول
قال السفير السعودي في الخرطوم علي بن حسن
جعفر في مقابله مع العربيه ان عمليات
اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب في السودان مستمره
واشار الى ان المملكه ساعدت باجلاء رعايا
دول عده فلنستمع لما قاله في هذه المقابله
اتمنى بالشفاء التامه اجلاء الرعايه
السعوديين
والرعايه الدول الخليج بسفرائهم منذ ثلاثه
ايام وصلوا بحمد الله الى
المملكه بيسر وسلامه
ولكن هناك بعض السعوديين الذين يتواصلون
معنا ولم نكن على علم بهم وهم في عدد من
الولايات السودانيه ونتخذ الاجراءات
اللازمه في ترحيلهم منذ ان عرفنا
بمقرات تواجدهم وعديد منهم قادر الامس
بالليل
واما عمليه الاجلاء بصفه عامه فهي مستمره
لكل
الرعايه الاجانب
الذين طلبت دولهم ان
تقوم المملكه بمساعدتهم بالاجلاء والوصول
الى مدينه جده ما هي ابرز الدول التي
انطلبت ان تنسق معها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه حتى تجلي بحكم
الامكانيات بحكم القرب ما هي ابرز هذه
الدول
حقيقه معظم الدول
غربيه وعربيه واسيويه
فمثلا
رجلين الرعايه امريكان بريطانيين
ايرانديين
وغيرهم ثم
وصلت الرغبات من المغرب وتونس وموريتانيا
والجزائر والباكستان وتايلاند
واليابان وماليزيا وهذا
ورعاياهم البعض منهم وصل واجلناه والبعض
سيتم خلال هذه الليله
والايام القادمه اجلاهم بالسلام ان شاء
الله الليله ان شاء الله ستغادر سفينه
بحموله 2500 شخص
مختلفه الجنسيات من مختلف الجلسات نحن
جهزنا على مدار 24 ساعه طاقم سعودي
لاستقبال
وتجهيز وانهاء جوازات الاجراءات الرسميه
للاجلاء
سواء هنا في هذا المقر او
بالتعاون مع اجهزه الشرطه السودانيه
هذه الملاسمه اود ان ارفع
ما وصلني من شكر وتقدير
كل سفراء ورعايه الدول التي اجليناها او
الدول المتوقع اجلال عياها
للقياده الحكيمه
ولما قدمته المملكه من يسر وتيسير
لاجلاء مواطنيها الى المملكه والتعاون
والتنسيق في داخل المملكه ما بين
اللجان السعوديه الرسميه
المكلفه بالاجراء وسفارات هذه الدول
هل من جهد متوقع للمملكه والرباعيه
الدوليه في تهدئه الاوضاعف السودان اخي
العزيز
الجهود
المجموعه الرباعيه الاليه الثلاثيه لم
تتوقف لحظه
قبل الاندلاع الاعمال الاغتاليه وبعدها
وما زلنا
ولعلك تعرف انه كان هناك دنتين كانت بسبب
العمل ادوا
للمجموعه الرباعيه والاليه الثلاثيه
ومواطنين سودانيين
وجدوا من
مصلحه الوطن ان يكون هناك
تحديه وان شاء الله ما زال العم مستمر
للوصول الى وقف الاطلاق النار والعوده الى
الحوار لان الحوار هو الاساس الذي سيحقق
ان شاء الله تطلعات الشعب السوداني في
السودان مستقر وموحد باذن الله طبيعه
الخطوه القادمه
نحن الان في تواصل مع الطرفين
هم من الاول هو ايقاف اطلاق النار بعد ذاك
سنبحث الخطوه التاليه ان شاء الله
رعايه ودبلوماسيون كوريون قادمين من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم الى قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه في جده في اطار
عمليات الاجلاء عقبه استمرار وتصاعد
الاشتباكات المسلحه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريعه
[موسيقى]
اذا في تصريح خاص للعربيه عبر سفير كوريا
الجنوبيه في السعوديه عن امتنانه
الاستضافه المملكه للمواطنين الذين تم
اجلائهم من السودان فلنستمع لمقاله
في كوريا الجنوبيه وكسفير كوريا الجنوبيه
في السعوديه اود ان اعبر عن تقدير وامتنان
للملك وولي العهد لجهودهما واستضافتهما
للمواطنين الكوريين في السعوديه
الى ذلك مشاهدينا بحث وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان مع مديره
الياباني جهود وقف التصعيد في السودان
وايضا ذكرت وكاله الانباء السعوديه ان
الطرفين تطرقا الى مساله انهاء العنف
وتوفير الحمايه اللازمه للمدنيين وتهدئه
التوترات المتصاعده في عدد من المواقع
الحيويه داخل البلاد
قالت مصادر العربيه ان عمليات اجلاء
المصريين من الخرطوم وام درمان ستحتاج الى
مزيد من الوقت مشيره الى ان القاهره تعمل
مع الجيش السوداني على ممرات امنه لنقل
الرعايه من الخرطوم هذا واضافت المصادر
مشاهدينا بان مصر تتوجه نحو بدء عمليه
اجلاء لمواطنيها عبر ميناء بورسودان
واضافت ايضا ان هناك اصابات بين المصريين
في السودان منها اصابات متوسطه
هذا ودخل نحو عشره الاف لاجئ سوداني الى
الاراضي الواقعه في جنوب السودان خلال
الايام الماضيه هربا من القتال الدائر
فيما عبر الحدود نحو 6500 لاجئ سودانيه
يوم السبت الماضي في وقت لا تزال الاعداد
اللاجئين مرشحه للزياده مع استمرار
المواجهات بين الطرفين
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الجزائريه اليوم عن
اطلاق عمليه اجلاء لرعاياها من السودان
والراغبين في مغادره البلاد ابتداء من
اليوم مشيره في بيان لها انها تتابع وعن
كسب الوضع بالسودان عبر خليه الازمه ومن
جهه اخرى اعلنت السفاره الليبيه في
الخرطوم عن اجلاء وخمسه من رعاياها في
السودان عبر باخره انطلقت من ميناء
بورسودان الى مدينه جده في السعوديه
من لندن تنضم الينا الدكتوره رؤى عربي
صحفيه واعلاميه تونسيه
السودانيه عفوا اهلا وسهلا بك استاذه رؤى
سابدا من موضوع الاجلاء الاجلاء الغربي
تحديدا ولكن اشرق السياسي منه اليوم
وبالامس فردت كل يعني الاعلام الغربي
لتحليل الموقف الامريكي والغربي العام
للقول بان هذا الموقف اخطا التقدير
بتطورات الوضع في السودان
وذهبوا الى التصديق كل ما كانت القياده
العسكريه تقوله للوفود الرسميه الغربيه
وتحديدا الامريكيه الى اي مدى تعتقدين بان
الامريكيين اخطا اخطاوا التقدير
بانذار ما ستؤول اليه الامور في السودان
مساء الخير اول حاجه حابه اطرحهم على
شهداء السودان
وخالص العزاء للاسر السودانيه
بدءا من عمليه اليوم الاجلاء لمواطنين دول
اجنبيه تمت على قدم وساق سواء جيش
السوداني او الدعم السريع الاثنين عندهم
تصريحات اهتمام بعمليه الاجلاء وبنتفق انه
نعم الاداره الامريكيه اخطات والعالم كله
اخطا في تحليل الازمه السودانيه لم
يتوقعوا التفاقم او الضحى يدخل في الحرب
بهذه السرعه وحتى تاثيرات الحرب كانت
تاثيرات فظيعه جدا لمده ايام قليله احنا
بنتكلم عن اكثر من اسبوع بقليل السوداني
فيه والكثير من التدمير الكثير من التشريد
الكهرباء الغاز انعدام
الاساسيات الحياه حتى
مع وجود المستشفى ياتي الوضع كارثي بكل
المقاييس اليوم يعني بالرغم من من اجراء
واتمام عمليه يعني اجلاء الدبلوماسيين
والرسميين من العاصمه السودانيه لكن هناك
رعايه لدول اجنبيه اذا ذهبنا يعني من
الجانب الامريكي نتحدث عن المئات وايضا عن
المئات من دول اخرى تسعى الاداره
الامريكيه
لاستحداث ممرات بريه طبعا بسبب اغلاق
المطارات
لتمرير ولاجلاء هؤلاء من العاصمه وصولا
الى بورتسودا نحن نتحدث ان الطريق البري
ليس امن ابدا وبالتالي العمليه ستكون صعبه
ومعقده
بمعرفتك بالداخل السوداني وبطبيعه يعني
نشاط هذه المجموعات المسلحه هناك هل ممكن
ان تحترم طرق ممكن ان تستصلحها اليوم او
يعني تخلقها الادارات لتمرير المدنيين
هي تم اقامه اكثر من هدنه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع ولكن الطرفين كانوا ما
بيحترموا الهدنه وكان بيتم الهجوم
والاثنين
كلا يلقي الاتهام على الاخر الشواهد من
السودان بتقول انه الدعم السريع بيهاجم
حتى مرات الممرات اللي بيخرج فيها
السودانيين او غير السودانيين تمت الكثير
من الشركات من قبل الدعم السريع تمت
مهاجمه الكثير من السيارات عندنا في
الايامات السابقه شهداء وقعوا نتيجه رصاص
قوات الدعم السريع والشوارع غير امنه في
مناطق بسيطر عليها الدعم السريع احنا
بنتكلم عن بحري بسيطه وسيطره كامله حتى في
الخرطوم اليوم وقعت قذائف فبالتالي حتى
الشوارع ما امال للخروج العمليه الاجلاء
هتكون صعبه وحتاخد زمن
هنالك زي ما قلت الكثير من الانتهاكات
والاختفاءات القصريه كذلك
اليوم نتحدث عن حوالي سته عشر الف مواطن
امريكي فقط من مزدوجي الجنسيه موجودين
داخل السودان هذا غير المواطنين
الاوروبيين المواطنين يعني من جنسيات اخرى
الموجودين هناك من المعلوم بان نشاط
الجماعات الارهابيه بدا تحديدا بعد العام
برز داخل السودان وطبعا بالقاره الافريقيه
اليوم هل ممكن ان تستفيد هذه الجماعات من
يعني من وجود هؤلاء هناك لتنفيذ عمليات
ارهابيه ممكن ان تؤذن الوضع اكثر وطبعا
تعقد الحوار والطريق السلمي لهذه الازمه
انا استبعد وجود عمليات ارهابيه لان
الطرفين بالاصل يقوم بالقتل
وضرب المدنيين احنا بنتكلم عن قوه الدعم
السريع هي ميليشيا موازيه للجيش بتقوم
بانتهاكات كثيره الانتهاكات يصورت حتى على
الكاميرات المراقبه للمواطنين سواء كان في
المحلات التجاريه في البيوت اللي هم دخلوا
ينهبوها ويسرقوها لما نتكلم عن جماعات
متطرفه احنا بنتكلم عن الان هنالك عسكر
موجود في السودان يسيطر على المشهد له
الحظ الاكبر في اثاره العبث والفوضى
اختفاء للشرطه السودانيه التي كانت لا
تختفي عند قمع المواكب لكن تختفي الان في
حفظ الامن والامان الوضع في السودان فوضوي
بكل انا لا استبعد كذلك الجماعات
الارهابيه ولكن ليس بالقدر الذي يتم
الاشاره له شكرا لك يا رؤى عربي صحفيه
واعلاميه سودانيه حدثتنا من
المدى الزمني للنزاع الدائر حاليا في
السودان غير واضح لكن اجلاء الدول
لدبلوماسيه وراعيها يؤشر لخطورته وطول
امده حيث تتواصل عمليات وجهود اجلاء
البعثات الدبلوماسيه العربيه والاجنبيه
والرعايه العرب والاجانب من السودان مع
استمرار المواجهات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع فمسارعه الدول الغربيه وبمقدمتها
الولايات المتحده لاجلاء الدبلوماسيه
واغلاق السفاره مؤشر واقرار ضمني بان
الحرب الدائره قد لا تتوقف قريبا قرار
الدول بني وفق مراقبين على استبعاد تسويه
عبر المفاوضات او حسم احد الطرفين المعركه
لمصلحته سريعا كما ان الخطوه الامريكيه
بارسال فريق استجابه للكوارث الى المنطقه
لتنسيق الاستجابه الانسانيه للمحتاجين
داخل وخارج السودان يعني غياب اي مساء
جديه او خطه ملموسه لوقف القتال في
السودان ليبقى السيناريو الارجح والاكثر
ترجيحا هو استمرار المع ارك وحينها كل طرف
من اطراف النزاع سيبحث عن زاعمين له
للصمود في المعركه لاطول فتره ممكنه
وبالتالي تعميق الاسماء علما بان هدنات
عده فشلت وفر الاف السودانيين بحثا عن
الامان وان كان الى تشاد المجاوره الفقيره
ففي الخرطوم حاليا لاما ولا كهرباء
والاصول الامن للطعام غير مكفول
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا قبل ان اتابع تطورات الوضع
السوداني ساشير الى هذا العاجل الذي يرد
الان رويترز اشتعال النار بطائره تابعه
خلال اقلاعها من عاصمه نيبال وتحاول الان
الهبوط اذا
طائره مدنيه تعود لفلاي دبي
تشتعل النيران فيها
فور اقلاعها من عاصمه النيبال وتحاول الان
الهبوط والعوده الى المدرج مجددا
[موسيقى]
اذا بحسب المعلومات الوارده الان الطائره
التابعه لشركه فلاي دبي وطبعا طيران
الامارات تحاول اما الهبوط في مطار
نيودلهي او العوده الى العاصمه النيبال لا
معلومات حتى الساعه عن سبب الحريق ولا عن
اذا ما كان يعني سيكون الهبوط امن على امل
ان يكون امن طبعا هذه الصور الاوليه
والفيديو الاولي الذي نشاهده عن عمليه
اشتعال النيران بهذه الطائره التابعه
والتي طبعا تتبع لطيران الامارات
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا ساعيد واشير الى ما كنا
نذكره مع هذا الفيديو الذي شاهدناه
النيران اشتعلت بطائره تعود دبي اي لطيران
الامارات اشتعلت فيها النيران فور اقلاعها
من مطار النيبال وهي طبعا
تحاول الهبوط في نيودلهي او العوده الى
العاصمه النيبال ساعود الى المسار مسار
الطائره فور اقلاعها طبعا هذا هو المسار
الجوي لها
اذا هذا
المسار الجوي للطائره التي كما ذكرنا
اقلعت من مطار النيبال اشتعلت فيها
النيران وهي تحاول الان العوده اما الى
مطار العاصمه او الهبوط في مطار نيودلهي
لا معلومات حتى الساعه كما ذكرنا عن سبب
اشتعال هذا الحريق في الطائره ان كان تقني
او اي سبب اخر لا معلومات عن عدد الركاب
وطبعا لا معلومات عن عمليه العوده والهبوط
اذا ما كانت ستكون امنه وطبعا سهله بظل
اشتعال النيران بهذه الطائره وطبعا ايضا
لا معلومات باي جزء من الطائره اشتعلت
النيراء
على كل حال مشاهدينا في حال يعني وجود اي
او ورود اي جديد حول هذا الموضوع سنعود
اليه خلال هذه التغطيه بالعوده الى تطورات
السودان قبل العوده الى تطورات السودان
سابقى طبعا
بموضوع اشتعال الطائره طائره تابعه خلال
اقلاعها من عاصمه النيبال وهي تحاول الان
الهبوط اما بالعوده الى مطار النيبال واما
بالهبوط في مطار نيودلهي كما ذكرت
مشاهدينا هذه المعلومات الاوليه بحسب
الصور التي تابعناها لا معلومات عن اعداد
الركاب لمعلومات عن سبب اشتعال النيران
ولا معلومات عن يعني الاجراءات الاوليه
التي يقوم بها تقوم بها السلطات هناك طبعا
يعني سيكون هناك اجراءات
لسلامه الراكبين الموجودين على متن هذه
الرحله ولضمان عمليه هبوط امنه هذا فيديو
اخر ايضا وصلنا
لمسار كيف اندلع الحريق في الطائره
فور اقلاع من
[موسيقى]
اذا يعني فيديو مقلق جدا وحادث مغلق جدا
يعيد الى الاذهان حوادث الطيران وخصوصا في
القاره الافريقيه التي يعني دائما ما تحصل
على امل ان تكون عمليه الهبوط امنه
فلنتابع الفيديو ومشاهدينا
اذا مشاهدينا في حال ورود اي جديد حول هذا
الموضوع سنعود اليه طبعا خلال هذه التغطيه
بالعوده الى التطورات السودانيه ولتغطيه
العمليات العسكريه الدائره هناك تسارعت
عمليات اجلاء الرعايه والدبلوماسيين
الاجانب من السودان ومخاوف السودانيين
تتزايد من طول امد الحق
دول العالم تسابق الزمن لاجلاء رعاياها في
السودان في وقت تتواصل فيه المعارك
الداميه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع لكن
امال السودانيين في انهاء الحرب تتقلص
ويتسع حجم المخاوف من طول امد الحرب
تقديرات محليه ودوليه
دلاله واضحه الى موجه عنف مقبله وهو ما
يراه السودانيون دليلا على غياب افق الحل
السياسي في البلاد واستمرار النزاع
الدائري ليصل امتداده الى الاحياء السكنيه
رساله المجتمع الدولي واحده وقف الحرب
واسكات المدافع والبدء في الحوار والبحث
عن الحل السياسي لانه لا يوجد حل عسكري
لهذه الحرب وهذا ما نقوم به من خلال اخراج
مواطنين لست مضطرا للشرح ما يحدث هناك
تراه انت تشاهد التلفاز لذلك يجب ان يخرج
مواطنون ومن المستحيل الاستمرار في العمل
كدبلوماسي لذا فان افضل شيء تفعله معهم هو
اخراجهم
اصوات اطلاق الرصاص وداوي الانفجارات يطغى
على دعوات التهدئه ويزيد من تعقيد عمليات
اجلاء الرعايه المحاصرين بين الجانبين
المتحاربين رغم تعهدات دوليه واقليميه
باسكات البنادق والتوصل الى تسويه سياسيه
سلطان العربيه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ينضم الي الان في الاستوديو
عثمان بنين رئيس تحالف قوه الخلاص الوطني
السوداني اهلا وسهلا بك استاذ عثمان سابدا
من موضوع الاجلاء ولو تطرقت اليه بطريقه
سريعه بما اننا كنا نتحدث عنه اجلاء اليوم
الدبلوماسيين تقريبا قد تم يبقى اجلاء
المدنيين هل يعني طرفي النزاع ممكن ان
يحترموا اي طرق بريه تستحدث في الفتره
المقبله لاجلاء المدنيين من هناك
في البدء بالحقيقه هو يعني اجراء
دبلوماسيين الاجانب هو يعني يعني
عرفي معروف يعني في كل الدول العالم لو
حصل اي نزاع فبيتم يعني على حسب يعني
التطورات الاوضاع على الارض اما بالنسبه
للمدنيين نحن نرى انه يعني الان الاوضاع
ابتدت يعني تحدث في الارض بين الطرفين
يعني ليست يعني في البدايه والان الصراع
عندها حوالي عشر ايام مما حصل اندلع
المواجهات بين الطرفين ولكن هنالك الان
يعني النداءات من القوى السياسيه في
الداخل وايضا من الاتحاد الافريقي ومن
الامم المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي لطرح
مبادره
لانهاء هذا الصراع الموجود بين الطرفين اي
من الاطراف اليوم قادره على اختراق جمود
الازمه خصوصا ان الصراع بين الطرفين هو
صراع كسر عظم اذا صح التعبير
هو بالحقيقه الان يعني الصراع الانتقامات
يعني ولكن اي صراعات او اي حروب يعني تحصل
لابد ان تعود الى مائده المفاوضات مائده
المفاوضات هي اللي بتحسم اي صراعات واي
نقاط خلافيه بين الاطراف
المتصارعه فحاليا الصراع يمكن يعني معروف
يعني ليس صراعا ايدولوجيا او صراعا يعني
صراع سلطه واذا ما تغذى صراع السلطه الان
بالماء الموجود لدى الطرفين ولكن بالسلاح
بالدعم الخارجي للاستفاده من ساحه السودان
تصفيه حسابات هناك وايضا يعني جعل السودان
قاعده لمنطلق جديد اليوم يمكن الاستخطابات
هل حصلت يعني في الفتره الماضيه جزء معين
من القوى السياسيه استختبط يعني قوات
الدعم السريع
لصالحه وكذا ولكن الان يمكن عرفوا الخطا
بتاعه في جزء كبير يمكن من هذه القوه الان
يعني اعتذروا على الهواء مباشره وقدم
اعتذاره للشعبي وفي الجزء الاخر وما زال
في اخرين يعني ما زال باللغه السودانيه
قاعدين يقابروا يعني ويتكلموا يعني ولكن
نحن رؤيتنا الان نحن في انه كيفيه ايقاف
هذه الحرب اللعينه التي اندلعت على رؤوس
الشعب السوداني والناس لابد ان تعود الى
مائده المفاوضات وهنالك الان مبادره ان
شاء الله سوف ترى النور يعني خلال 24 ساعه
القادمه تحت مظله الاتحاد الافريقي وهذه
المبادره ايضا
هي محل قبول من احد الاطراف هذا السؤال
الاساسي في مبادرات كثيره ولكن ليس هناك
اي مبادره محل قبول من قبل اي من الاطراف
يعني ثوره قبل المبادره الطرفين يقولون
نحن جاهزين عند المبادره لا تسمع الا
البيانات بيانات الاتهام بين الطرفين هو
بالحقيقه يمكن التحدث منظمه يعني عالميه
معروفه ونطبها انه حل النزاعات الموجوده
في القاره الافريقيه والان الرئيس الاتحاد
الافريقي للدوره لهذه العام
السيد الرئيس جمهوريه جزر القمر وفي مع
السيده البرهان وفي تواصل مع السيد حميته
الطرفين وجدوا يمكن يعني وجد الضوء الاخضر
من الطرفين والان ان شاء الله يمكن خلال
هذا الاسبوع يعني هم راح ينزلوا الخرطوم
وراح يقابلوا الاطراف والطرفين وثم بعداك
يطرحه الاليه على النقاط المحدده يعني
المبادره فنرى انه ان شاء الله يعني نحن
ندعو يعني الطرفين للتحكيم صوت العقل
وايضا يعني ان هذا الشعب اللي هم يتصارعوا
من اجله الشعب الان رفض الطرفين لن يقبل
الان يعني مستقبلا اي من هؤلاء الطرفين
انه ان يحكموا مستقبلا
دعني اتطرق الى نقطه اساسيه اليوم تثار في
حال ما ذهبنا نحو فوضى داخل السودان
معناها يعني الارض ستكون خصبه لاستقدام
لاستقطاب الارهاب والمجموعات الارهابيه
التي بالاونه الاخيره بعد الحرب التي شنت
على داعش في افغانستان انتقلت من الى
افريقيا لتكون هي المنطلق لعملياتها
الارهابيه في العالم اذا ما ذهبنا نحو
مسار الفوضى الذي سيكون موجود في حال يعني
طال امد هذه الحرب الفقر قلات التعليم عدم
وجود يعني الاساسيات كلها ستدفع الشباب
نحو هذه التنظيمات هل تخافون من هذا
الموضوع على مستقبل السودان نعم نحن الان
يمكن نخاف على غير غير غير التنظيمات
الارهابيه الاخرى الان نحن نخاف انه ان
تتحول الى حرب اهليه ولكن عزانا في هذا
انه ان شاء الله يعني لن تتحول الى حرب
اهليه قبليه لانه هذه القبائل السودانيه
كلها يعني اصبحت قبائل متصاهره ومترابطه
مع بعضها البعض فلن يحصلون النزاعات
بيناتهم يعني بين القبائل المتعدده
السودانيه وايضا المجتمع الدولي ينظر الى
السودان انه لابد ان يتم استقرار السودان
ايضا الوضع الامني لابد ان يكون مستتب في
السودان لانه السودان الان يعني محيط به
حوالي 7 دول محيطه بالسودان وايضا خلف
السبع دول اخرى اي نزاع في السودان واي
انهيار للم نظومه السودانيه الامنيه
وخلافه سوف تؤثر على المنطقه الافريقيه
ككل يعني بصوره عامه
الاستقرار اليوم يعني هناك عنوان عريض
يستخدمه الغرب وهو صانعي المشكلات الروس
ووجودهم داخل السودان وداخل القاره
الافريقيه التي عزز يعني طبعا الوجود
الروسي عبر فاجنر وعبر مؤسسات وشركات اخرى
اليوم وجود هذه المجموعه هناك نتحدث عن
الذهب عن الشركات التابعه لها وكل
التقارير حول هذا الموضوع هل ممكن ان تؤجج
ويعني
امد الصراع خصوصا وان هناك شيء معروف داخل
السودان بان حتى ايام الرئيس البشير هو
يعني استعانه بالروس عندما كان هناك خوف
على ولايته ووعدهم ان تكون السودان هي
الباب للقاره الافريقيه
يمكن يعني الان الروسي عندهم يعني علاقات
بالحكومه السودانيه وهنالك الان اتفاقيات
كما تفضلت يعني منذ لنظام الس 2017
اتفاقيات لاقامه قاعده عسكريه في على
المحرك
وايضا الان هنالك يعني اتفاقيات مع قوات
الدعم السريع وفي اتفاقيه مع الروس وعلى
راسها انه خلافه ولكن نحن الان يهمنا انه
استقرار البلاد بغض النظر نحن عن الصراعات
الدوليه هذه السرعات الدوليه لن تفيد
الشعب السوداني ولا تفيد الانسان السوداني
نحن الان السودان دوله زاخره ودوله يعني
غنيه كما تفضلتي بموارد المتعدده ولكن
الاغلب الموارد ومن الافقر من حيث الدخل
من حيث نصيب الفن نعم هذا كله يعود يعود
الى القيادات الموجوده لانه تكون قي
ادات يعني ليس لديها مثلا بقدر على
التخطيط والتنظيم واداره الدوله او قياده
فاسده فساد وفشل وصراع داخل وكل ما انها
شكرا لك عثمان بوني رئيس تحالف قوه الخلاص
الوطني السوداني على وجودك معنا شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الولايات المتحده انها سترسل سفنا
من اسطولها البحري لاجلاء رعاياها من
السودان وقال المتحدث باسم البيت الابيض
انه ليس هنالك عمليات اجلاء كبيره وان
الوقت غير مناسب لاجراءها كما اضاف ان
عشرات الامريكيين يتحركون بريا مع قوافل
الامم المتحده الى
هذا واعلن المبعوث الاممي للسودان عن وصول
700 من موظف الامم المتحده ومنظمات اخرى
الى بورسودان بالاضافه الى اجلاء اثنين
وسبعين موظفا اماميا من دارفور الى مؤكدا
على بقاء الامم المتحده في السودان ودعمها
للشعب السوداني بكافه الوسائل الممكنه حتى
حل الازمه
مشاهدينا اتابع واياكم شهاده لاحد سكان
منطقه الكلاكله جنوب الخرطوم والتي تعرضت
اليوم لقصف مروحي فل نتابع
اهلا بكم الان اطيل عليكم من المكان الذي
تدمر عدد من المنازل التي تدمرت في جنوب
العاصمه الخرطوم وتحديدا الكلاكله القبه
شارع 15 عدد من المنازل تدمر التماما
هنالك عدد من الضحايا وعدد من الاصابات تم
على فكرها نقل الى مستشفيات القرب من جنوب
العاصمه الخرطوم
تحدثوا الينا عن الاصابات وعن المنازل
التي تدمرت ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتاكد
تماما لماذا تم قصفه هذا المكان منطقه
الكلاكلات عموما منذ سلاحات الاشتباكات لم
تشهد اي مواجهات صراع عسكري بين قوات
الدعم السريع وقوات الشعب المسلحه حتى
هنالك عدد كبير من سكان وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم جائوا الى الكلاكله
للاحتمال بهذا المكان لم يتاكد لنا مصادر
بان هذا القصف من اين تموت تم من الطيران
الحربي ولكن معظم الاهالي يقولون بانها
جاءت قصفات عشوائيه
مشاهدينا اتابع واياكم ايضا فيديو اخر
لعمليه القصف في منطقه الكلاكله
اكيد اياتنا حاجه كده ما نعلم بها الله بس
كل الناس دي وقعت والمراوح والبيت وقع وكل
شيء بس الحصر
مصدر حاجه الحاصله ان شاء الله ما في ناس
يتعودت
ودون مستشفى التركي
وعندها جرح كبير وعندها سكري رقدوها في
منور
وجارنا واحد يتوفى
جارنا جاي توفى وحولينا كل العرج بتاع
البيت كله اي زول
ما في حاجه نحنا يعني البيت نهار نهاي ما
في حاجه تاني بيت النهار كله يعني سبحان
الله ما في ولا اي حاجه ولا معلقه من
البيت
الحمد لله ربنا يعوضنا بابرك منه ان شاء
الله وجاي علينا ان شاء الله دخل عليه
وما عندنا اي شيء ولا عندنا زول عنده
ضديات لا دي والحله الحله نهائي ما عندها
اي حاجه يعني 12 بيت 13 بيض ده ولا عندنا
معسكر ولا عندنا اي حاجه ناس احنا ساكنين
في محل عشوائي زاد كله ما في حاجه يعني
ولا نحن منتمين لاي لا لا لا
الناس في حالنا يعني نحن ناس في حالنا ما
عندنا حاجه ايوه يعني سبحان الله
سرعه الحله كلها البيوت كلها منهاره يعني
اي زول
سبحان الله الحمد لله نحمد الله ونكون
من عباده والحمد لله الحمد لله الحمد لله
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من القاهره ابي عز
الدين المحلل السياسي السوداني استاذ ابي
او ابي عز الدين المحلل السياسي السوداني
استاذ ابي سابدا من موجه الهجره التي طبعا
يعني بدانا الحديث عنها منذ ايام وهي
تتسرق رقعتها يوم بعد يوم اليوم باخر
العواجل الذهاب نحو اثيوبيا نحو تشاد نحو
كل الدول المحيطه بالسودان وايضا طبعا
مصر ستكون ايضا وجهه هذه الموجه النزوح مع
ما تعنيه من فوضى بالمنطقه المحيطه
للسودان هل ممكن ان تحرك اكثر وتضغط اكثر
على ان كان دول الاتحاد الافريقي او جنوب
افريقيا او الدول الغربيه
لتسريع الضغط على افريقيا النزاع الى حل
سياسي
بدايه نتمنى الطائره السلايد دبي بسلام
وكذلك هبوط طائره النزاع السودان بسلام
بالنسبه لهذا الموضوع
بدايه
سمعت اليك قبل قليل تحدثي عن الطريق او
ربما نتحدث عن طريق ان يكون امنا
للاجلاء انبه انه ينبغي ان يرافق الطيران
الحربي السوداني كل هذه
الجهود عبر المعابر البريه هذه نقطه مهمه
جدا لم اشاهد اي اثر للطيران الحربي خارج
الخرطوم يرافق هذه
الجهود هذه يعني بخصوص هذه النقطه وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه يعني قالت بالساعات
الماضيه انها تبحث عن خطه خطه امنيه
لاخراج كل من يريد من يريد الخروج من
السودان الى بورت سودان طبعا مع ارسال سفن
حربيه الى هناك مع ارسال يعني فرق
لتضمن الطريق وامانه هذه
الاجلاء امانه عمليات الاجلاء طبعا
ينبغي ان يكون بالتنسيق التام مع القوات
المسلحه والا سيظهر الموضوع الذي ذكرته
قبل قليل حول نشاط الجماعات الارهابيه
التواجد الامريكي غير مرحب به عموما في
دول العالم الثالث كما تعلم
هذه نقطه جوهريه هنا بان الجماعات الا
اولا ترفض السلام مع اسرائيل ثانيا ترفض
الوجود الغربي ثالثا ترفض كل عمليات
الانتقال الديمقراطي ويعني عمليات مسار
تحول المجتمع السوداني نحو نحو الافضل
وبالتالي
وترفض حتى الانظمه المدنيه والعسكريه هي
ترفض الجميع حتى الانظمه العسكريه طبعا
لديها فيها راي الموضوع ليس متعلق بمدنيه
او عسكريه متعلق بالايديولوجيا
والاقصاء الذي لديهم طب هل ترى بما انك
تتحدث عن الموضوع بانها اصبحت ارض خصبه
لبلاد يعني عاش فيها حتى اسامه بن لادن
حوالي الخمس سنوات
اسامه بن لادن كان في فتره لم يكن مصنفا
ارهابيا وقتها حضره كمستثمر من السعوديه
لم يحضر من افغانستان فالامر مختلف ولكن
اريد ان اشير الى موضوع
اثر الاجلاء على مواقف الدول الكبرى يعني
ربما ربما تاخرت بعض الدول او ما طرد في
ادانه هذا التمرد او وصهي بالتمرد لانه
حقيقه تمرد عسكري ربما لوجود الجاليات
وخوفها من ان يتم استخدامهم كدروع بشريه
مثل ما استخدمت الميليشيات الحاليه
المواطنين السودانيين كدروع بشريه
فاتمنى ان هذا الاجلاء يساعد هذه الدول
على ان تقوم بالادانه للضغط على الجميع
لانه اذا التمرد تعجل بانهاء الازمه لانه
حاليا هنالك اشارات تشجع على التمرد قبل
قليل رايت في شريط العربيه ان فرنسا
والاتحاد الاوروبي يتحدثون عن وصول
للتسويه
ويتم دعوه الحكومه الى الوصول لا تسويه
معها
حتى اذا اردت الوصول الى يجب ان تضعف هذه
الجماعات المتمرده او الارهابيه قبل
الجلوس اليها
طبعا فرنسا تقاربت مع حمل
من عباءه عباءه روسيه
بين الطرفين وهي تعقد المشهد اكثر شكرا لك
استاذ
ابي عز الدين المحل السياسي السوداني من
القاهره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات